Çeviri: Tayfun Günal
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Bu konuşma teklifi geldiğinde
çok heyecanlandım.
Çünkü TED'i başından beri izliyorum.
Ve öğrencilerime de sürekli izletiyorum.
Hatta bunu Türkiye'ye getirme konusunda
ne kadar iyi olur diye
bir öğrencimle konuştuğumda
bir süre sonra öğrencimin
sizinle birlikte çalıştığını gördüm.
Çok mutlu oldum.
Heyecan verici bir şeydi.
Hele konu ilham perileri olunca,
ben de ne biliyim,
belki yaratıcı düşünme teknikleri
konusunda konuşurum.
Kriz gibi meselelerden bahsederim dedim.
Ama onu hemen terk ettim.
Ve buraya geliyordum, o arada
ilham perilerini bekliyordum
fakat ufukta hiçbir şey görünmüyordu.
Kızım o arada bana bir konuşma gönderdi,
bir TED konuşması.
Önce İngilizce kelimeyi anlamadan
izlemeye başladım.
Erteleme konusunda bir konuşma,
procrastination diye bir kelime.
Ortalarına doğru
çok keyifle izlediğim konuşma
birden bir karabasana dönüştü
benim için.
Çünkü benim hâlim
adamdan daha kötüydü.
Ortada bir ilham perisi görünmüyordu.
O sırada da bu salonun
düzenlenmesiyle ilgili
Berrin Hanım bizi çağırıyordu
sık sık geliyorduk.
Aşağıdaki ilham perilerinin
yanına gidiyordum.
Onların karşısında o satranç
takımı var aşağıda ya,
onlardan medet umuyordum
şu gördüğümüz görüntüden.
Fakat hayır
gene...
Onları izlerken aklıma birden
kendi satranç takımım geldi.
Yıllardır çok büyük bir keyifle
kullandığım
ve bir örneğini daha görmediğim
bir satranç takımıydı.
Çünkü buradaki piyonlar, yani askerler
engelliydi.
Bakın.
Tahta bacaklı.
İşitme engelli.
Bunu dedim bu müzeye hediye edeyim.
O arada birdenbire
engellilerle ilgili yaptığımız
çalışmalar geldi.
Benim ilham perim, evet.
Buradaydı.
Engellilerdi.
Onun üzerine son yaptığımız projeden
söz etmeye karar verdim.
Yıllarca mimar olarak çalışmıştım.
Mimarlık eğitimi almıştım.
Çeşitli konularda, ODTÜ Teknokent'te,
engellilere yönelik projeler yapıyorduk.
Bunların kimi
görme engellilerle ilgiliydi,
kimi işitme engellilerle.
Bunun, bu konulardan bahsetmenin,
uygun olacağına karar verdik.
Ve son projemizden bahsetmek istedim.
Fakat
Berrin Hanım'la yaptığımız
konuşmalarda sanal gerçekliğin
önemini de, birlikte konuşuyorduk.
Ve, biz bilgisayar oyunları yapıyorduk
aynı zamanda, bilgisayar oyunlarının
sanal bir dünya yaratmak konusunda
ne kadar önemli olduğunun farkındaydık.
Hatta sinemadan bile gerçekçi
bir ortam yaratabiliyordu.
Her sanat eserinin temel sorunu zaten,
bildiğiniz gibi, inandırıcı
dünyalar kurabilmesinde
onun üzerine son
projemizi anlatacağım size.
Bu arada, aşağıda bazılarınız görmüştür.
Bir simülatör var,
bir tekerlekli iskemleden yola çıkarak
ama biraz değiştirdik
çok ürkütücü olmasın diye.
Çünkü, biliyorsunuz insanlar
tekerlekli sandalye gördükleri zaman ya da
engelli birisini gördükleri zaman
biraz uzaklaşıyorlar.
Birkaç gün önce,
ben bu konuyla uğraşırken
ODTÜ Teknokent'teki ofisimize girdim.
Orada bir baktım,
birisi oturuyor tekerlekli iskemlede,
bir Cumartesi günüydü çok kimse de yok.
Hemen yanına yanaştım.
''Kalıcı mı?''dedim.
Hayır, dedi adam.
Kalıcı değil, neyse ki kalıcı değil.
Nasılmış engelli olmak dedim.
''Vallahi,'' dedi:
Ben burada, askeri bir rehabilitasyon
merkezinde çalışıyorum.
Ve her gün,
engelli insanlarla çalışıyorum.
Fakat, bu iskemleye oturduğum zaman ilk
defa anladım, nasıl bir duygu olduğunu.
Müthiş bir şey, dedi.
Bu çaresizlik duygusu, korkunç bir şey.
Düşünün, yangın olsa kaçamayacaksınız.
Bunun üzerine yaptığımız projenin
küçük bir videosunu gösterdim.
Çok etkilendi, biz zaten yıllardır
müzelerde mesela, engelliler görsün diye,
dokunabilsin diye,
çünkü onlar sahiden
görmek kavramını kullanıyorlar.
Eserlerin replikalarını yapıyorduk.
Birkaç müzemizde bu proje devam ediyor.
Engelliler için, Braille alfabesinden
kurtulmalarını sağlayacak projelerimiz var
ve o ilham perilerinin bize,
bir telefonla bildirdiği son projemiz,
bu, Empati Sokağı projesi.
Bir gün bir telefon çaldı,
ben Eskişehir'de otogardaydım.
Bizim işlerimizi, müzelerde yaptığımız
işleri gördüğünü,
kendisinin de bir engelli olduğunu
ve bir dernekleri olduğunu,
engellilerle empati kurmasını
sağlamak üzere
bizimle çalışmak istediklerini söyledi,
ben de sevinerek kabul ettim.
Sonra toplantılar başladı.
O toplantılar esnasında, onlar
bir parkurda bunu denetmek istiyorlardı.
Biz de o sırada sanal gerçeklik
gözlükleriyle uğraşıyorduk.
Bunu, bu konuya uyarlamaya karar verdik
ve
çalışmalara başladık.
35 kişilik bir ekiple çalışıyoruz.
Bu tekerlekli iskemleyi önce
tekerlekli iskemle olarak kullandık.
Denemeler yaptık, kendimiz kullandık.
Engelli arkadaşlar sürekli
denettirdiler, denediler.
Ve bize yardımcı oldular.
Bu bir ortak projedir.
Empati Sokağı Projesi,
Sağlık Bakanlığı falanla da görüşüldü.
Onlardan izin istedim
burada anlatmak üzere
daha şeye girmedi,
yürürlüğe girmedi proje.
Sonunda, bunun bir tekerlekli iskemle
olmaktan biraz çıkmasını,
insanlara cesaret vermesini istedik,
ilk korkuları yenmeleri için.
Ve bir, engelli arkadaşlarımızın
anlattığı, bizim de her gün gördüğümüz
birtakım sorunları burada canlandırdık.
Bunlar neler, aşağıda deneme fırsatı
bulursanız zaten göreceksiniz.
Gözlükle, sanal bir ortama giriyorsunuz.
Bu alandaki en gelişmiş
gözlüklerden bir tanesi, Oculus.
Piyasaya henüz çıkmadı.
Bu gördükleriniz, aşağıda kullanılan da
geliştiricilere verdikleri bir model.
Piyasaya yeni yeni çıkacak şimdi,
biraz fiyatı falan da arttı.
Ama insana benzersiz bir deneyim sunuyor.
İnternete bakarsanız birkaç
tane konuşma da var,
TED konuşmalarından birkaçı da var.
Empati yaratma gücü açısından
olağanüstü gözlükler bunlar.
Çünkü kendinizi o ortamda hissediyorsunuz.
Burada dolaşırken
sokakta, tekerlekli iskemleyle yürümenin
ne demek olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Diyelim ki, evinizden çıktınız, karşıdaki
bir otobüs durağına gitmek zorundasınız.
Bunu bir oyun hâline getirdik.
Rampadan inmek istiyorsunuz, tekerlekli
iskemleyle ama oraya bir araba park etmiş.
İnemiyorsunuz.
Devam ediyorsunuz.
Bir üst geçit var.
Rampayla, oradan çıkmaya gücünüz yeterse.
Çünkü çoğu zaman,
o kadar indik ki o yokuştan
tek başınıza onu süremiyorsunuz.
Birilerinin yardım etmesi lazım.
Diyelim ki yukarı çıkmayı başardınız.
O çabayla.
Üst geçidin öbür ucuna gittiğiniz zaman,
orada merdiven olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Bir daha rampa yok.
Bu sefer geldiğiniz yere geri dönüp
oradan inmeniz gerekiyor.
Onu burada deneyebiliyorsunuz.
Birkaç gün önce ben denediğimde
aşağıya bağırarak indim,
çünkü düşüyor gibi oluyorsunuz.
İnsanlara bunları anlatmak istedik.
Ben, bu süreçte şunu anladım.
Bazen ilham, düşündüğümüzden
çok daha yakında oluyor.
Uzakta aramaya gerek yok.
Ve bu projeyle
anlatmak istediğimiz şey de şu:
Biz kendimizi, engellilerden ayırıyoruz.
Ama engeller biraz yüksek olduğu zaman
özellikle de yaşınız ilerlemeye başladığı
zaman bunlar daha görünür hâle geliyorlar.
Yüksek bir kaldırım,
çıkamayacağınız bir duvara dönüşüyor.
Bir çocuk arabasıyla,
bir kaldırımdan inmeye ya da
bir üst geçide çıkmaya kalktığınızda
siz de artık bir engellisiniz.
Ve engellilerin, şu sıralarda aralarında
konuştukları terminoloji şu;
biz engelli değiliz,
engellenmiş durumdayız.
Engelleri kaldırın.
Biz de normal olarak
yaşamaya devam edelim.
Umarız, bu projeyle
bütün insanlara bunu anlatabiliriz
ve kentlerimiz başka türlü şekillenir.
Daha duyarlı hâle geliriz.
Teşekkür ediyorum.